la situation qui va nous intéresser
aujourd'hui est la suivante
imaginez une personne immobile sur terre
et une personne un astronaute situé dans
la station spatiale à une certaine
altitude de la terre
l'europe a dessiné la station spatiale
avec un peu de détails simplement pour
se repérer ce qui va nous intéresser
c'est de calculer la dilatation du temps
pour ces deux personnes donc chacune
porte sa propre horloge
on va appeler 71,1 étaient deux et ce
qui va nous intéresser c'est de savoir
comment et dilatés le temps de la
personne dans la station spatiale par
rapport au temps de la personne sur
terre lors le rayon de la terre sera
notée grand air l'altitude de la station
qui n'est pas du tout à l'échelle ici
sera notée petite hache et puis on
utilisera le temps d'une personne très
lointaine de la terre et de la station
comme référence qu on notera petit et
l'idée ici ça va être d'utiliser la
relativité générale pour calculer ses
effets de dilatation temporelle et en
particulier il ya deux effets différents
qui vont entrer en jeu c'est l'effet de
la gravitation de la terre qui exercent
une dilatation du temps sur les deux
corps ainsi que l'effet de la vitesse de
la station spatiale qui est en orbite
autour de la terre en orbite circulaire
et l'effet de sa vitesse va également
infligé une dilatation temporelle aux
astronautes notera petit v la vitesse de
la station pour analyser cette situation
on peut considérer que la terre est à
peu près ce ferry quai statique et
utiliser la métrique de schwarzschild
qui permet de décrire ce genre de
situation en relativité générale donc la
métrique de charte qui s'écrit de la
façon suivante
c'est carré d'été carré facteur de 1 -
rs sur r - dr carrés sur un mois et sur
r - errecart et défis carré alors le ds
carré ici dsc la l'intervalle la
distance que parcourt chacun d et deux
observateurs dans l'espace temps donc
quand on prend en compte l'espace et le
temps quelle est la distance que
parcourt un de ces observateurs et en
particulier ceux des escarres et est
directement liée au tant que mesure
l'observateur puisque le temps une
horloge en fait va simplement mesurer la
distance qu'on parcourt dans l'espace
temps donc ce dsk ray on peut
directement dire qu'il est égal à des
tocards et utp c'est le temps propre de
l'observateur donc c'est soit tu es 2 si
on s'intéresse à l'observateur dans la
station spatiale août et ainsi on
s'intéresse à l'observateur sur terre et
donc plusieurs langues a noté des taux
et le tout avec un facteur c'est carré
c'est la vitesse de la lumière dans le
vide et ça va être uniquement pour
convertir les unités de temps en unités
de longueur
donc ce que nous dit cette équation la
métrique de chartes il sait que le temps
qui s'écoule pour un observateur est
liée aux écoulements de ses coordonnées
d'été étant l'écoulement du temps de
l'observateur très lointain r ici petit
air étant l'altitude de l'observateur
donc pour l'observateur sur terre c'est
ce grand air pour l'observateur de la
station spatiale ses grands airs plus
l'attitude de la station h le tour
apporter un certaine longueur qu'on
appelle le rayon de schwarzschild rs qui
est liée à la masse de la terre
de cette façon là donc mc la masse de la
terre chez c'est la constante de
gravitationnelle de newton et ce rayon
de chartes il représente en fait le
rayon que devrait avoir un trou noir
avec la masse de la terre alors pour la
terre sur yon churchill vous quelques
millimètres donc il est vraiment tout
petit et se r s / r est vraiment
infiniment petit par rapport à
ensuite ici on a les intervalles de type
espace donc dr sela variations
d'altitude et fille ici c'est l'angle
que forment l'observateur par rapport à
certains axes qu'on aura choisi donc par
exemple l'angle de la station spatiale
qui varient au cours du temps
bon et bien commençons par calcul et la
dilatation temporelle subie par
l'observateur sur terre
cet observateur on va reprendre la
métrique de shark shield est notée ces
carrés des t1
arrêt puisque ce sont en propre on l'a
appelée t1
est égal à tout ceci mais alors dans
tout ceci l'observateur lui est immobile
son altitude air ne varie pas et son
angle fille ne varie pas donc ces deux
termes val 0 pour cet observateur le
seul terme qui va contribuer c'est celui
ci donc on peut directement écrire que
ces 2 dt 1/2 est égal à ses 2 dt2 le
temps de l'observateur très lointain
facteur de 1 - rs sur air est petit et
récits c'est le rayon de la terre pour
cet observateur
et si on a déjà presque terminé suffit
de diviser par ces carrés des deux côtés
et puis on passe tout à la racine carrée
et on n'obtient que des t1 sur d'été est
égale à la racine carrée de 1 - rs sur r
ceci c'est notre premier résultat de
dilatation temporelle et il s'agit en
particulier d'une dilatation
gravitationnelle puisque l'observateur
ne bouge pas et on voit effectivement
que la grandeur qui intervient ici c'est
le rayon de schwarzschild qui dépend de
la gravité et en particulier de la
constante de newton de gravitation j'ai
ce que nous dit cette formule c'est que
lorsqu'une seconde c'est cool pour
l'observateur très lointain un peu moins
d'une seconde puisque ceux ci est
inférieure à 1 ce sera d'écouler pour
l'observateur sur terre donc en
particulier cet observateur sur terre
vieillit moins vite que l'observateur
lointain
bon et bien maintenant on peut refaire
le même calcul mais cette fois ci pour
la personne dans la station spatiale
alors je vais mettre les séparations ici
et on va s'occuper de la deuxième
personne pour cet observateur sont en
propre on leur a noté des t2 donc des t2
au carré est égal et on va réutiliser
les termes de la métrique alors cet
observateur ne varie pas non plus
d'altitude son altitude ne change pas vu
qu'il tourne autour de la terre en
orbite circulaire donc ce dr vos héros
par contre le déficit ne vaut plus zéro
puisque l'angle de la station varie au
cours du temps donc ici on peut écrire
ces deux dt 2 1 - rassurèrent
- air de défi de et on voit ici que la
formule est différente de la formule
précédente précisément parce que la
station est en mouvement et donc ce
terme vient s'ajouter
alors ici ce qu'on aimerait c'est
pouvoir déterminer des t2 sur d'été la
dilatation du temps et donc ici on
aimerait pouvoir diviser tout ça par
d'été or ici on a un des filles qu'on
aimerait exprimé du coup en proportion
de dt alors que vaut ce défi et bien en
fait il va être liés à la vitesse de la
station puisque plus la station se
déplace vite plus l'angle de la station
fives arrive vite
alors ici on va faire la proxima sion
que l'on se trouve en mécanique
newtonienne et en particulier que la
station est suffisamment loin par
rapport au rayon de shark shield ce qui
est effectivement le cas pour considérer
que sa vitesse est exprimée en fonction
du temps infiniment atteinte et donc on
va dire que la vitesse de la station
c'est la distance qu'elle parcourt des
ailes dans l'espace / le temps qui s'est
écoulé et du coup par l'approximation
prend le temps infiniment l'indre
alors ça c'est simplement vitesse égale
distance parcourue sur temps écoulé
ceci est égal à quelque chose qui va
dépendre de la variation d'angle puisque
la distance parcourue par la station si
on imagine un arc de cercle comme ça
cette distance ici des ailes c'est la
longueur d'un arc de cercle de rayon r +
hb donc la longueur d'un arc de cercle
ses rayons x angles et d'angles défis
dont qui s'y est refusé facteur de
défier le tout divisé par dt
et si ça nous arrange puisque le défi on
peut en réarrangeant les termes
l'exprimer par rapport à d'été on
n'obtient que des filles est égale donc
des deux côtés aurez x d'été et / r + hb
on obtient des filles est égal à vdt sur
et sage
converger que dans cette expression ici
on obtient ces carrés d'été carré
facteur de 1 - rs et le petit air ici
pour la station spatiale c'est le rayon
de la terre plus l'altitude de la
station - errecart est pareil c'est le
rayon de la terre plus l'altitude de la
station au carré facteur de défi au
carré tout ça au carré
vkr et d'été carré / r + h au carré
l'aide de herses usagers 6e supprime
et on obtient ces carrés d'été carré 1 -
rs sur r + hb
- v carré d'été carré
alors ici on va faire le même travail
qui si on va diviser des deux côtés de
l'équation par ces carrés donc en
divisant
ici bien c'est carré qui va paraître
donc en particulier le terme qui
intervient c'est le rapport entre la
vitesse de la station et la vitesse de
la lumière ça ça nous indique bien qu'on
est dans un cadre de relativité puisque
on compare les vitesses à la vitesse
limite qui est la vitesse de la lumière
et maintenant on va pouvoir diviser par
dtcc arrêts des deux côtés passez le
tout à la racine carrée et on n'obtient
que des t2 sur d'été la dilatation
temporelle de l'astronaute dans la
station spatiale est égale à la racine
carrée de un bon rs sur r + hb
- des carrés sur ces carrés
et ceci c'est notre deuxième résultat
c'est la dilatation temporelle subie par
l'astronaute dans la station
alors on voit comme l'altitude de la
station est différente la dilatation
gravitationnelle ici n'a pas la même
valeur elle est plus faible pour la
personne dans la station puisque air
plus haché plus grand donc rs sur l'air
plus âgées et plus petit donc la
personne dans la station son temps est
moins dilater par la gravité puisque lé
plus loin de la terre mais par contre il
ya un deuxième effet de dilatation qui
s'ajoute c'est l'effet de la vitesse
d'orbites de la station
alors pour conclure ce qui va nous
intéresser c'est de savoir quel est le
rapport entre ces deux grandeurs quelle
est la dilatation du temps dans la
station par rapport au temps de la
personne sur terre
donc ce rapport c'est dt2 sur des
terrains
c'est à dire que c'est des t2 sur d'été
sur des terrains sur d'été peut diviser
au numérateur et le dénominateur par dt
et donc ça va être le rapport de ces
deux expressions ici c'est à dire la
racine carrée de 1 - rs sur r + hb - v
carrés sur ces carrés sur un moins rs
sur le long terme
alors ce rapport est un peu difficile à
lire comme ça et on va pouvoir pour
terminer faire quelques approximations
pour l'exprimer dans une forme plus
simple et plus lisible
alors on a vu que le rayon de chartes il
est vraiment tout petit quelques
millimètres par rapport à des distances
qui s'exprime en centaines voire
milliers de kilomètres
donc ici rs sur des distances de
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres c'est
un film entier de la même façon la
vitesse de la station spatiale est très
petit par rapport à la vitesse de la
lumière donc ce terme est aussi un film
anti donc ce qu'on va faire c'est
utiliser des développements limité c'est
à dire des approximations lorsque des
termes deviennent très petit pour
réarranger un peu tout ça sous une forme
plus lisible alors les développements
limité qu'on va utiliser sont les
suivants je vais les notés en rouge on à
la racine carrée de 1 - x lorsque x est
très petit c'est à peu près égal à 1 - x
sur deux ensuite on sur la racine carrée
de 1 - x
c'est à peu près 1 + x sur deux
est pour l'instant ces deux
développements limitée vont nous suffire
donc ici on voit qu au numérateur on a
une racine de 1 - tout ceci qui est très
petit donc on va pouvoir dire que ceux
d'été deux sur des terrains est à peu
près égale à 1 - x sur deux donc ce x
c'est tout ça sur deux donc rs sur 2 r +
hb -
v2 sur deux c2
et au dénominateur on a un sur racine
13h54 donc tout ça est équivalent à 1 +
x sur deux dans tout ça est un plus rs
sur deux aires
là on peut distribuer tout ça donc tout
cela est à peu près égale à 1 - eres sur
2 r + hb
- v carrés sur deux c'est carré donc là
j'ai distribué tout avec le 1 qui est
ici plus
rs sur deux aires fois le inquiète ici
et ensuite les autres termes vont tout
simplement être encore plus petits
puisque ici on a un terme très petit
multiplier avec des termes très petit
donc on a un ordre supérieur dans le
développement on peut négliger le
produit de ce terme avec ces deux termes
et donc cette approximation et valides
et en fait est une très bonne
approximation
à partir d'ici on va pouvoir faire une
seconde approximations qui est de dire
que l'altitude de la station h alors ici
elle n'est pas du tout représentée à
l'échelle mais en fait dire que cette
attitude est très petit par rapport au
rayon de la terre alors cette
approximation est moins bonne que celle
qu'on a faites précédemment puisque h
est de l'ordre de 400 km d'altitude pour
la station spatiale et air et de l'ordre
6400 km de rayon pour la terre donc on a
quand même un rapport qui est supérieur
à 10 entre les deux donc h c'est plus
petit que 0.1 fois r donc on a quand
même un rapport d'échelle qui est assez
grand assez conséquent mais le rapport
est moins important l'approximation et
moins bonnes que celles qu'on a faites
précédemment mais bon par souci de
clarté on peut quand même faire cette
approximation et considérez donc h sur
air est très petit par rapport à 1
lorsqu'on fait ça ici c'est le seul
terme dans lequel h intervient on va
vouloir le décomposer donc rs sur deux
facteurs de r + hb
c'est égal à ars sur deux aires
facteur 2 1 + hachuré 1
1 sur un plus sage sur r c'est un autre
développement limité que je vais écrire
ici
un sur un +6 c'est à peu près égal à 1 -
1 6 lorsque x est très petit donc tout
cela est à peu près égale à ars sur deux
aires
facteur de 1 - h horaire donc ici notre
d'été deux sur des t1 est à peu près
égale à 1 - rs sur deux aires
facteur de 1 - 1 h / r - vkr est sûre de
ses deux plus et reste sur deux aires
à partir de là on va utiliser un
résultat de la mécanique newtonienne
pour exprimer la vitesse de la station
pour l'instant la vitesse on ne l'a pas
exprimé mais en fait la vitesse d'une
orbite circulaire dépend uniquement de
son altitude par rapport au centre de la
terre
la mécanique de newton la gravitation
newtonienne qui est une très bonne
approximation dans ce quart d'heure
glossy nous donne que la vitesse est
égal à racine carrée de gm sur air
l'attitude alors ici l'attitude de la
station spatiale ses grands airs puce h
donc ici il faudra encore une fois
utilisé notre approximations que h et
très petit par rapport à m une première
chose qu'on voit ici c'est que v carey
va être de la forme
gm sur r + hb
et donc v carrés sur ces carrés va être
de la forme j'ai et main sur ces carrés
sur air plus
et si on reconnaît le facteur qui
correspond au rayon de schwarzschild
divisé par deux donc ici on peut
exprimer tout ceci par rapport au rayon
churchill v carrés sur ces carrés est
égal au rayon de churchill / 2 / r + hb
et en fait on se retrouve avec
exactement la même expression qu'on
avait en dessous et reste sur 2 r + hb
et reste sur deux airs plus sage donc on
peut utiliser cette même approximation
ici et dire simplement que v carrés sur
deux c'est carré est égale à la moitié
de ceux-ci et donc est égale à la moitié
de ceux ci ont tout ça ici ça nous donne
environ 1 - rs sur deux aires à 1 - 1 h
/ r
- c'est carré sur deux c'est carré c'est
à dire moins ceci sur deux donc moins rs
sur 4 r 1 - lâche horaires
plus et reste sur deux aires
ici on va pouvoir combiner ces deux
termes ici en disant simplement que ce
terme et reste sur 2 rc 2 rs sur quatre
aires en multipliant par deux en haut et
en bas et donc quand on additionne ces
deux là le de ici + 1 va devenir trois
donc tout cela est à peu près égale à 1
- 3 rs sur quatre aires fois un montage
surya est ce un moyen sûr et on va
directement le développer donc fois hein
ça nous donne ça - assurèrent donc plus
3 rsh sur quatre r2 et plus ce errait
sur deux aires qui est ici qu'on va
également pouvoir incluant
dans le terme qui se trouve là donc ici
on a moins trois quarts + 1/2 le tout
fois et ray sur r
et ça si on met au même dénominateur on
a deux sur quatre donc 2 sur 4 - 3 sur 4
ça fait moins un sur quatre est donc
tout cela est égal à 1 - errer sur air
sur 4 + 3 rsh sur quatre perd 2 et pour
terminer ceci est à peu près égale à 1 -
rs sur quatre aires
facteurs ici on va pouvoir factoriser
tout ça par erez sur 4 r 1 - et donc et
reste sur quatre heures il nous reste 3
h / r
ceci c'est à peu près la dilatation du
temps subi par la personne l'astronaute
dans la station spatiale
par rapport à la personne sur terre et
pourquoi j'ai mis tout ça sous cette
forme un peu compliqué alors que la
forme précédente étaient exactes ici on
a une forme approximer et bien c'est
tout simplement parce que ici on voit
directement que ce h sur air est très
petit on se rappelle que l'attitude de
la station spatiale est très faible par
rapport au rayon de la terre et donc ce
1 - 3 assurèrent est plus grand que 0 il
est à peu près égale à 1
si ça c'est positif alors tout cela avec
le moins c'est négatif et donc tout ça
est inférieur à 1 ce que cela signifie
c'est que du fait que la station est
très proche de la terre
se ternissent y est positif et donc la
dilatation du temps subi par la personne
parle astronautes dans la station est
inférieur à 1 autrement dit la personne
dans la station vieillit moins vite que
la personne sur terre on aurait pu
s'attendre à linverse la personne dans
la station et plus loin du centre de la
terre et donc elle subit moins d'
influence gravitationnelle mais du fait
de sa vitesse d'orbites elles subissent
davantage de dilatation par la vitesse
que de différences de dilatation par la
gravité